You know how Christians had a Christmas songs
and Jewish people have Adam Sandler?
We kwanzaa's don't have a song of our own.
Oh, well, I didn't really realize that you
were Kwanzaa.
I'm half on my mother's side.
That's why we celebrate Christmas.
Oh, okay. Okay.
That's Kwanzaa and Christmas together.
Yeah, that's a conjunction function, Keenan.
That's what that is right there.
And I'm sick and tired of all my white women
asking me about the meaning of Kwanzaa.
Jay, how many white women you got?
Enough for each night of Kwanzaa.
Okay, I'm saying I got a lot.
I mean, everybody can get.
I don't just be sprinkling in the snow.
Okay, I understand.
Understood.
I like that, all right, so I wrote a nice
little Kwanzaa song for everybody, you know
what I mean? And I was wondering if I could
debut it on y'all's show.
No, no.
Well, thank you, Kevin. I'm gonna do it
anyway. Hit it. Avery.
Oh.
You know, you got a white man playing a
keyboard.
He's albino. Kevin.
He's albino.
Oh, sh*t. I'm sorry.
We apologize. Okay.
Sorry, sir. We didn't know.
Sorry. Just saying. Okay.
He's one of them. John B's.
Gotcha.
Gotcha. John B's.
That's what it is. Okay.
People often ask me, what does Kwanzaa mean?
Well, I just googled it, so now I know
everything. Gather round.
Why did Kwanzaa is a hoot?
Dashikis gift giving and a sh*t ton of
fruit. Grapes.
Seven candles for seven days.
These are the facts.
Light the kinara.
It's a menorah for people who are black.
L' chaim! Day one ummoja unity of race.
Support the cause by gifting me a Gucci
suitcase. Gucci.
Day two self-determination is kujichagulia.
Damn it.
Nothing rhymes with kujichagulia.
Buy a vowel!
Kwanzaa.
Kwanzaa. Got a smile on my face.
Kwanzaa. Kwanzaa.
Where's my Gucci suitcase?
Ship it. Ujima.
Ujamaa. Those are the days three and four.
Ujamaa is also the girl who gave me the clap
in oh four. Day five reminds us of our
history. Speaking of history, we're doing
this sh*t for free.
Now wait a minute.
With what? Yeah.
Caring for community on day six is what we
do.
Kumba.
How about I sing and you don't sing?
Yeah.
No, I know.
It's not always about you.
Hit it. Kwanzaa.
Kwanzaa is like our Christmas.
We're on colored people time.
So we start on the 26 day late.
Imani means keep the faith.
That is day seven.
Kwanzaa needs an elf on the shelf.
So how about you, Kevin?
He Tiny.
Wait, wait a second.
That's just ridiculous.
Did you just. Did you just come on my show
and then make a short joke on me?
Well, technically, I made it, and he just
hyped it.
Short joke. Okay.
Oh, Kwanzaa.
Kwanzaa. A holiday for every race.
Kwanzaa.
Kwanzaa. Uh, Mr.
Pharrell?
Oh, it's my Gucci suit..
case.
No.
Uh, says here you just got served by Ujama.
Oh, man. Ujama again.
Huh? Mhm. She'd be tripping.
Well, you know what they say.
Hell hath no wrath like ujama when child
support is not paid.
Mhm. Again.
Ujama. Ujama.
Why are you still so mad?
Oh, Ujama.
UJama. I told you I'm not the dad.
Maury!
Maury, wait a second.
Yes. All right.
Jay. Happy Kwanzaa, guys.
And guess what? We'll be right back.